[Musique]
bonsoir esprit de conquête
tout a commencé en 1983 lorsque mon ami
bruno pour son anniversaire c'est lui
offrir un micro-ordinateur ce petit zx81
souvenez-vous celui qu'on vendait dans
le catalogue la redoute 1986 mon
grand-père s'interrogeant mophie un des
plus beaux cadeaux
à l'époque c'est ce que je pensais un
ordinateur un micro ordinateur à moi
cette fois ci lorsque j'ouvre il est
deux cartons de mon amstrad pc 15 12
j'étais le plus heureux
les adolescents je dispose est à présent
d'un ordinateur cga quatre couleurs d'un
lecteur de disquettes 360 ko et comble
du tout d'un disque dur de 10 méga
octets révolution 1987
je travaille pendant deux semaines et
demie dans un félix potin vous de ces
deux semaines je peux m'offrir un jouet
fabuleux je voulais ramener ce soir il
s'agit d'une quête calculatrice hp 28
aces
notation polonaise a amorcé pour les
connaisseurs 2 ko de mémoire fabuleux
cette calculatrice fut pour moi un
élément remarquable
très sincèrement parce que pour la
première fois dans n'importe quel cours
au lycée
lorsque celui ci était soporifique je
pouvais mettre un avis démonstration
esprit de conquête tout le monde aurait
pu penser que j'oriente mes études vers
l'informatique choix personnel facteur
humain j'ai fait un tout autre choix je
me suis orientée dans le monde de la
santé
quelques années plus tard j'étais
infirmier diplômé d'état 1995
internet est parmi nous c'est une
révolution
il est impossible de me joindre sur ma
ligne téléphonique
je suis connecté à l'ensemble du monde
pour échanger sur tout et n'importe quoi
et pouvoir essayer de faire avancer un
certain nombre de choses j'exerce dans
un service de réanimation chirurgicale
à paris on m'offre la possibilité de
réaliser le site internet de celui-ci
nous sommes le premier service de
réanimation en france et services
hospitaliers de france à mettre en ligne
nos procédures nos protocoles de soins
et nos modes opératoires je reçois le
prix de l'innovation du salon infirmier
européen esprit de conquête
j'aurais pu rester dans le monde
hospitalier
une carrière météo ferté ouverte j'ai
fait tout autrement
j'ai décidé de devenir entrepreneur
entrepreneurs dans les nouvelles
technologies 2000
google a deux ans facebook n'existe pas
encore je crée ma start-ups il veille le
portail des paramédicaux francophone une
base d'informations qui permet à tous
les soignants et pratiquants de soins
francophone d'échangés collaborer
innover un an plus tard je suis racheté
par un groupe
mon projet devient emploi sante.com il
existe toujours un esprit de conquête
2004 je me lance dans le développement
d'applications full web pour la santé
ordonnances électroniques traçabilité du
médicament au lit du patient outil
collaboratif pour les soignants 2004
tout va très vite
le web évolue naissance de facebook
je sais pas si j'aime mes naissance de
facebook
les choses avancent ibm annonce la fin
de l'ibmp c'est les gens du web ont
gagné les choses continuent à avancer
esprit de conquête en 2007
je fais un tout autre choix je pars dans
le monde de l'internet et plus serait
précisément le monde des datacenter ses
centres de données qui héberge tout ce
qu'on trouve actuellement sur la toile
en quelques années je m'amuse j'innove
et je me fais plaisir en essayant
d'imaginer des datacenters éco
responsable aujourd'hui nous sommes
considérés comme un des acteurs majeurs
dans le monde
sur ces innovations mai
est ce là l'esprit de conquête
tout ce que je viens de vous raconter
figure à peu près dans mon profil
linkedin mais que connaissez vous de moi
qui suis-je
connaissez-vous mes émotions mes
sentiments qu'est ce que je connais de
vous hormis peut être une image un
profil saviez-vous
peut-être avant ce soir pour certains
que je ne porte jamais les mêmes
chaussettes
les choses s'accélèrent plein de
questions se posent aujourd'hui et ça
m'interroge depuis dix ans réellement je
m'interroge sur la vitesse à laquelle
avance ce média cet outil depuis dix ans
le vocabulaire évolué on m'a parlé de
streaming on m'a parlé de like
on m'a parlé d'objets connectés on m'a
parlé de big data on m'a parlé d'
intelligence artificielle
on me parle maintenant de
transhumanistes mme et d'hommes augmenté
tout comme technophile que je suis cette
année j'ai fait un truc complètement
dingue je les fais je vous assure je
suis parti en pèlerinage
un vrai pèlerinage celui du geek absolue
je suis allé au cs de las vegas on m'a
présenté plein de trucs
alors ça a commencé par des véhicules
intelligents
ensuite on m'a présenté des applications
intelligentes
ça a continué après avec des objets
intelligents et pour finir
fin du fin on m'a présenté des slips
intelligent si si je peux le blackpad et
slip intelligent ça existe on pourra en
parler plus tard après cela on m'a parlé
de la ville intelligente et des
entreprises en plus qui vont devenir
intelligente imaginer je suis resté
assez perplexe je vous avoue face à tout
ça et je me suis interrogé l'homme
n'est-il plus en mesure de réfléchir
seul une vraie question
qu'en pensez vous on m'a présenté tout
un tas de robots ou alors des robots qui
jouent au ping pong des robots qui sont
capables de faire tout un tas de choses
dans votre domicile mais dans les usages
professionnels
ce soir je voulais vous parler d'un de
ces robots il s'appelle peppers pepper
est un robot humanoïde qui devrait
prochainement être dans bon nombre de
services hospitaliers pour semble-t-il
être au plus proche de vous
comme je voulais indiqué tout à l'heure
je suis un ancien professionnel de soins
je vous présente ma main droite
à présent c'est une main quelconque est
la risée tout un tas de soins tout un
tas de choses techniques pour essayer
d'aider l'humain certes peppers pourra
peut-être un jour me remplacer pour
réaliser ses soins il néanmoins cette
main a aussi était capable de se poser
délicatement sur le front d'un enfant
lorsqu'il était inquiet la nuit dans
l'hôpital et ne trouvait pas le sommeil
cette main était capable d'appuyer sur
mon nez comme ceci pour le faire sourire
cette main a aussi tu es capable de
prendre une autre main vous savez cette
main
ou parfois on annonce à quelqu'un une
nouvelle sur laquelle parfois il peut
être gravement malade à cette main qui
vous accompagnent lorsqu'on vous annonce
la mort de l'un de vos proches
cette main aussi qui parfois donne la
main à une personne qui se retrouve seul
dans l'hôpital 100 personnes et pour
lequel vous serez le dernier contact
avant sa mort je m'interroge je
m'interroge sincèrement pour ma part
j'espère ne jamais avoir affaire à
pepper à la fin de ma vie en ce qui vous
concerne
je vous laisse le choix de choisir de
choisir de faire ce que vous avez envie
comme je vous l'indiquais aussi dans mon
domaine
je travaille maintenant dans les
datacenters et là je vois plein de
choses sincèrement fabuleuse on ne parle
d'un nuage le cloud c'est ce espèce de
truc opaque la voilà dans lequel on
vient stocker tout un tas de choses mais
tout ce qu'on stocke consomme énormément
d'énergie
cette énergie aujourd'hui elle est
phénoménale
greenpeace a sorti un chiffre il ya
quelques semaines indiquant que si
internet était un pays il serait le
cinquième consommateur énergétique ou un
d'électricité au monde
alors oui internet et virtuels on ne le
palper part on ne mesure pas mais on
peut se poser quelques questions
pour exemple vous savez cette photo
qu'on stocke dans le cloud ça reste un
petit peu comme un schémas fonctionnels
que vous connaissez on est dans sa
maison on stocke dans la cave et puis
après on stocke dans le garage on fait
la même chose quand on fait sa valise
pour partir en vacances on stocke et on
remplit on remplit un jusqu'à ce que
soient bien plein
la différence c'est que dans le cloud à
chaque fois vous mettez quelque chose ça
consomme de l'énergie
je vais repartir avec cette photo j'ai
46 ans
si je prends mon pari main ce qu'il rêve
ce que je découvre dans l'album familial
entre zéro et un mois liée à ma
naissance sur un mois de vie j'ai six
photos de moi me représentant enfants je
vous ai pas fait l'affront les amener
soir sinon vous n'auriez vu que mes
fesses mais néanmoins il n'y a que six
photos qui existent de moi je
m'interroge aujourd'hui quant au
fonctionnement des enfants qui naissent
ce jour et vous le savez pertinemment on
passe son temps à vouloir fixer un
instant et prendre tout un tas de photos
mais qu'est ce qu'on perd à vouloir le
fixer cet instant on est plus focalisé
vous perdez le regard le souvenir
l'émotion peut être du moment voulait
absolument le cliché fabuleux et on veut
tous ce cliché fabuleux je m'interroge
réellement et si l'esprit de conquête
était un esprit de reconquête de
l'humain de son environnement et de ses
émotions
aujourd'hui tout votre plus en plus vite
on avance à la vitesse de la lumière sur
la fibre avec l'hyper loupe demain on
fera peut-être paris rome en 50 minutes
on doit se poser de sérieuses questions
on gagne du temps mais pour quoi faire
on gagne du temps mais qu'est ce qu'on
perd voici les questions que chacun
d'entre nous devraient se poser est ce
qu'on gagne du bonheur gagnon
effectivement plus d'argent doit-on
gagner plus d'argent
où sont les émotions quid de nos
émotions
je m'interroge toujours de plus en plus
d'après vous
que restera-t-il d'un j'aime sur
facebook
dans 20 ans quid par contre d'un regard
d'une parole comme ce soir d'un sourire
une transmission d'émotion je
m'interroge vraiment on avance de plus
en plus vite
une stat ans on est encore sorti
récemment qui indique qu'un humain
actuellement passe huit ans de sa vie à
regarder un poste télévisés et cinq ans
sur les réseaux sociaux
et si l'esprit de conquête était un
esprit de reconquête de l'humain de son
environnement et de ses émotions
ce soir je pense que tous ensemble on
peut peut-être entreprendre ce chemin et
j'espère que vous accepterez peut-être
de le commencer avec moi à présent j'ai
juste vous demander de me faire
confiance
tout comme quand j'étais soignants et où
les gens me faisait confiance
je vais tout d'abord vous demander de
bien vouloir lever votre main droite
j'ai ensuite vous demander de bien
vouloir lever votre main gauche
si vous prenez quelques instants à
présent vous pouvez regarder votre main
droite et votre main gauche mais vous
pouvez aussi observer la main gauche de
votre voisin de droite et la main droite
de votre voisin de gauche
fabuleux si vous observez bien vous vous
verrez qu'il y a des petites mains des
grandes mains des grandes oies des
petits doigts certains d'entre vous ont
dû vernis à ongles
d'autres se sont rongés les ongles pour
d'autres encore ils portent des bagues à
une à plusieurs
l'esprit de conquête
à présent je vais vous demander avec
votre main droite de prendre la main
gauche de votre voisin
et avec votre main gauche je te prendre
la main droite de votre voisin bravo on
y est
l'esprit de conquête en moins de trois
minutes
tous ensemble nous venons de créer un
réseau social humain connectés
vous savez ce que m'apporte ce moment
une émotion une émotion parce que là
nous sommes tous ensemble
peut-être que en sortant de ce thé dicks
tout à l'heure vous viendrez à ma
rencontre pour échanger
je viendrai également à votre rencontre
pour échanger nous devons nous
interroger car les jeunes générations se
doivent non seulement de gérer une
transition énergétique dompter cette
révolution numérique et revoir
l'intégralité de modèles sociétaux
l'esprit de conquête
oui ensemble j'espère que nous pourrons
et je le souhaite
imaginez un monde dans lequel la
technologie soit au service de l'humain
et non humain au service de la
technologie
ce soir je suis heureux de vous avoir
rencontré et ce soir j'ai élargi mon
réseau social j'ai fait la connaissance
de 6 speaker tedx depuis cet après midi
par moments j'étais en stress par
moments j'ai été inquiet ils sont venus
vers moi ils m'ont souris ils m'ont
accompagné ils m'ont aidé et ce soir
devant vous j'ai quitté mon monde
virtuel pour venir dans le réel
j'ai osé victor hugo disait dans les
misérables osé le progrès est à ce prix
toutes les conquêtes sublime sont plus
ou moins le prix de hardiesse
merci
[Applaudissements]